[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ap
tout est sous contrôle
si on le décide et qu'on fait tout pour
ce soir je vais vous parler de la façon
dont on doit gérer les risques et
résoudre les problèmes en entreprise en
vous partageant mon expérience et en
démontrant que certes et techniques sont
nécessaires mais pas suffisantes et
qu'un comportement bien adapté est plus
que primordiale
alors je suis emmanuel molinero et j'ai
trois piliers dans la vie ma famille
la magie et le consulting et c'est des
deux derniers dont je vais vous parler
ce soir je suis effectivement
illusionniste et consultant en
management excellence opérationnelle et
pendant des années j'ai commis une
erreur
celle de croire que ces deux activités
étaient distinctes alors que bien au
contraire elles sont complémentaires
j'utilise en magie des techniques de
management et dans mon rôle de manager
des techniques de magiciens et je vais
vous expliquer comment
il y a quelques années j'ai participé à
un tremplin talent avec un ami magicien
dans ma normandie natale
et il s'agissait en fait d'un délire un
talent par catégorie il y avait des
humoristes des magiciens des chanteurs
et j'ai concocté pour l'occasion un tour
à lyon magie et mentalisme et le final
c'était que je retrouvais dans un kiwi
qui était devant la scène depuis le
début un nombre pensé par un spectateur
j'étais assez fier de moi et ça ça a
bien fonctionné
en revanche l'introduction
ça a été un peu plus compliqué
j'ai présenté vous connaissez peut-être
un classique c'est le journal pour
déchire et qu'on reconstitue
je connaissais par coeur sur le numéro
le faisait depuis dix ans je te
connaissait sur le bout des doigts c'est
qu'à le dire
c'est bien toi moi d'entrer en scène
j'ai le trac puisque ce soir
je comprends pas pourquoi parce que
finalement
il n'y a pas d'enjeu est ce que c'est le
fait de me mesurer à d'autres je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas il est bien là
en plus il règne une chaleur étouffante
dans la salle et ça ça n'arrange rien
mais j'entre en scène et me voici avec
un spectateur en train de déchirer du
journal
on s'échange les morceaux de papier et
on continue de déchirer joyeusement et
au moment de la reconstitution
le drame des morceaux de papier qui
tombe au sol
je fais semblant de ne pas avant
d'apercevoir le public ne le voit pas
vraiment en revanche le jury lui ou à
tous
et au moment du verdict tout
naturellement je suis disqualifié et je
passe une mauvaise fin de soirée et un
mauvais vous tiennent alors non pas
parce que j'ai je n'ai pas été
sélectionné non pas très grave non parce
que ce petit problème s'était manifestée
ce problème que j'avais enfoui depuis
des années car je le connaissais et je
m'en voulais le risque qui était resté
en berne pendant des années s'était
révélé ce soir là aux yeux du jury
mais pour moi ça a été un déclic
ne plus me faire surprendre par un
risques mal maîtrisées ou pire
sous-estimé je décide alors est bien de
résoudre le problème complètement en
utilisant des techniques de résolution
de problèmes que j'avais l'habitude
d'employer en entreprise je vais
chercher la cause racines à l'origine de
ce problème j'utilise les techniques en
question et je la trouve cette cause et
je suis même
étonné de voir la nature de cette cause
je place en face une solution radicale
pour l'éradiquer et ce numéro maintenant
je le présente encore de temps en temps
ça m'arrive de le faire avec confiance
et sérénité car ça fonctionne à 100%
100% c'est quand même confortable bon je
vous avoue une chose lors de la
reconstitution du journal j'ai toujours
un petit sourire nerveux qui se
dessinait au point de la bouche mais
comme le disait nelson mandela
je ne perds jamais soit je gagne soit
j'apprends et ce soir là j'ai appris sur
la technique le tour bien évidemment
mais surtout sur moi et j'en ai tiré
deux leçons la première le saut et pour
paraphraser la loi de murphy
syli à la moindre possibilité pour que
sarah ben ça ratera un jour ou l'autre
mais ça ratera alors pour contrer
justement ce risque l'idée est de mettre
une solution radicale concrètes en face
la deuxième leçon c'est que
non
on ne peut pas segmenter cloisonné ses
activités les compétences de lune
peuvent être intégrés dans l'autre
mais alors comment bien gérer le risque
en entreprise
je vois bien comment trouver les
solutions
il ya quelques années j'étais manager
maintenance dans l'industrie et des
situations à risque vous imaginez bien
que j'en ai connu un certain nombre
quand vous avez une ligne d'équipements
qui est à l'arrêt et l'arrêt en question
peut s'élever jusqu'à plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'euros par heure je peux
vous dire qu'il ya du monde sur le pont
et c'est assez stressant alors ces
années de pratique mon année à la
conclusion qu'il y avait trois
comportements clés à avoir pour contrer
le risque et trouver les bonnes
solutions
et pour moi le premier comportement en
question
c'est d'être dans l'action
oser agir
et il ya deux cas quand le risque ne se
manifeste pas encore et quand le risque
se manifeste alors dans le cas où il est
encore on va dire en berne il faut être
dans ce cas là
proactif
en ayant un coude avance être proactif
ça signifie anticipé le risque en le
prévenant c'est comme quand vous
conduisez votre voiture pour l'entretien
des 100000 km et quand vous changent les
pièces usées avant qu'elle ne soit
complètement hs et du bouton bien en
panne ou dans un autre domaine la
médecine chinoise où l'on consulte avant
d'être malade et être proactif c'est ça
signifie aller jusqu'au bout des choses
il ya quelques temps je me suis
intervenu dans une entreprise où il y
avait effectivement une liste de risques
dressé par des experts pour une zone
donnée très bien les cette liste était
restée lettre morte aucune action en
face aucun plan d'action planifier et ça
ce n'est pas bon
aller au bout dans le cas où
effectivement
le risque se concrétise là c'est autre
chose dans ce cas là il faut être
réactif réactif et parfois être réactif
et bien on peut sur réagir et c'est
dangereux de surréagir pourquoi parce
que l'on se fait contrôler
par notre cerveau reptilien et s'il y a
une pression ambiante qui est assez
forte il ya en a tendance à ne pas trop
réfléchir et de foncer tête baissée et
ça ce n'est jamais bon alors pour les
personnes qui ont du mal à garder la
tête froide dans la panique elles
pourront toujours faire intervenir trois
principes le premier c'est de suivre une
méthodologie une méthodologie de façon à
pouvoir à partir d'un raisonnement qui
est posé et réfléchi et bien
ne pas braver les étapes et déjà posé la
réflexion avant d'agir ne serait-ce que
15 minutes 20 minutes avant réfléchir
ensemble sur la façon dont on va
conduire les essais et les étapes qui
vont suivre de façon à ne pas passer à
côté de la solution parce que ça peut
être le danger la méthodologie le
deuxième principe c'est
utiliser l'intelligence collective je ne
suis pas seul j'ai des équipes autour de
moi je peux les solliciter je dois les
solliciter et je dis souvent que on est
plus génial à plusieurs que tout seul
et des équipes qui sont bien organisés
bien synchronisés avec l'émulation
collective qui va bien ça ce solo ce
sont les conditions du succès qui amène
derrière une dynamique de résultats
et puisqu'on parle d'intelligence
collective vous savez chez les animaux
ça existe aussi
chez les fourmis les oiseaux migrateurs
quand ils prennent leur vol
il se forme en v de façon à réduire leur
fatigue et ainsi pouvoir parcourir une
distance augmente et
l'intelligence collective le troisième
principe pour garder la tête froide
dans la panique et bien c'est d'utiliser
la mission alors je sais que c'est un
peu près ce qui est rationnel de parler
d'intuition quand on est raisonnée mais
il faut l'utiliser à bon escient et je
qualifierais l'intuition comme la somme
de toutes les expériences qu'on a pu
avoir dans sa vie et qui va faciliter
inconsciemment la prise de décision
finale
alors forcément je vous invite tous à
saisir toutes les opportunités que vous
pourrez avoir en face de vous de façon
ajustements alimenter notre expérience
est forgé ainsi votre intuition
le deuxième comportement clés importants
avoirs pour contrer le risque est passé
à l'action c'est de faire preuve de
leadership
alors qu'est ce que c'est le leadership
est bien c'est cette faculté à emmener
une équipe c'est en sport l'entraîneur
qui va coacher son équipe qui va donner
du positif qui va être enthousiaste
aussi qui va encourager eh bien c'est la
même chose dans l'entreprise il faut que
le manager et ces qualités là pour
avancer pourquoi parce que quand vous
allez gérer un risque en entreprise
vous allez mettre en place des plans
d'action et parfois le plan d'action en
question de la s'agir de demander aux
personnes de changer leurs habitudes
et c'est difficile parfois de changer de
zone de confort une zone de confort
c'est quoi je suis dans ma situation a
et on me demande de changer vers une
situation b parfois c'est un patron un
pas de 30 cm pour aller vers la
situation bien n'est ce pas sauf que
pour la personne qui doit faire ce pas
c'est comme si vous lui métier un fossé
de 200 mètres de profondeur c'est plus
la même chose
c'est pour ça que à cenon à ce moment là
il faut persuader avec des arguments
certes mais il faut convaincre avec
votre charisme votre leadership pour
justement rendre attractive cette
situation et pour que la personne se
rendre compte effectivement c'est dans
son intérêt d'aller vers cette situation
le troisième comportement clé qui est
important c'est de celle think outside
the box pensez à l'extérieur de la boîte
qu'est ce que ça signifie eh bien ça
signifie de ceux des formats t de la
vision qu'on peut avoir parfois qui est
étriqué d'avoir effectivement un champ
de vision rétrécie ce n'est pas bon
parce qu'un champ de vision rétrécie ça
signifie un champ des possibles bref
avec les six donc il faut prendre du
recul à voir cette faculté là c'est
comme ça qui effectivement on trouve des
solutions qui sortent juste avoir de la
boîte et pour illustrer mon propos je
vous ai ramené ici ah oui on se refait
pas une pièce regardez la pièce je la
place est dans ma main je vais pas
commenter tout ce que je fais mais
regardez ma pièce ah oui turquie ramé
manche
la pièce les deux manches tous passeront
les manches dans ma pièce
hop
on remercie
est pas utile 1 mais je vois que ça
vient du coeur
qu'est ce que je viens de faire un
instant je viens de contrôler votre
cerveau ou le méchant
j'ai conditionner votre mental par la
répétition du geste votre cerveau a
enregistré le fait que la pièce était
dans la main et effectivement je le
gardais dans la main droite mais
je vous ait conditionné en quelques
secondes imaginez à l'échelle d'une
journée d'une semaine d'art moins d'une
année
et c'est dangereux
transposé nous dans le monde de
l'entreprise vous voyez toujours les
mêmes les mêmes processus les mêmes
procédures en vigueur
compliqué de voir autre chose que ce
qu'on voit tous les jours c'est
difficile n'est-ce pas et il faut se
forcer justement à prendre ce recul
nécessaire et être dans la capacité de
réfléchir en dehors de la boîte
encore une fois
je vous donne un petit bonus en
communication ça peut vous être utile la
pièce vous l'avez vu dans la main
pourquoi parce que j'étais moi même
convaincu que la pièce était dans ma
main n'est ce pas j'ai été convaincant
parce que convaincu moi même que la
pièce était ici et c'est ce qu'on
appelle la congruence j'étais en accord
avec moi même et quand vous voulez
effectivement
transmettre un message à un auditoire
qui est deux personnes ou 20 au sens si
vous êtes en accord avec vous même avec
le message que voulait porter je peux
vous assurer que votre auditoire le
sentir et regarder tout mon intention
tout mon corps mon regard
insinuer inconsciemment que la pièce
était dans la main eh bien c'est la même
chose quand vous
voulez transmettre un message un public
alors en guise de conclusion on va faire
une expérience
je vois que ça vous fait plaisir
on va faire une expérience avec
avec ceux ci mais dans un premier temps
j'ai une petite boulette de papier alors
voilà ce qu'on va faire je vais lancer
la boulette il ya pas de risque car tout
est sous contrôle
pas de cailloux à l'intérieur la
première personne qui trouve la boulette
la lance derrière elle est la personne
qui réceptionnera la boulette viendra me
rejoindre comme ça on pourra pas dire
qu'il ya compérage vous êtes prêt
attention
abah
abah c'est madame merci madame vous
pouvez me rejoindre sur scène s'il vous
plaît elle est heureuse madame
encourager la
[Applaudissements]
petite mise en scène
voyage où je vais vous aider voilà merci
beaucoup votre prénom madame françoise
encourager de nouveaux françoise
ça va durer une minute en
voici
un clou c'est un vrai que vous pouvez à
tester
el haddioui
gens qui étaient passés sous contrôle
et le cloud représente bien évidemment
le risque voilà ce qui va se passer
françoise dans un instant je vais vous
demander de placer un gobelet alors je
pense celui ci mais vous pouvez prendre
celui que vous voulez vous aller cacher
le clou et ça on n'a plus besoin et dans
un instant vous à les mélanger les
gommer de façon à ce qu'on ne sache plus
où se trouve le clou elle est ici
endurance mais je ne vois pas le savoir
est ce que c'est bien clair ou bien
super et vous écarter bien les gobelets
les uns des autres et de façon à ce que
personne
personne ne vois je veux place devant et
françoise quand c'est fait vous me dites
alors contrairement à hélène je ne
chante pas beaucoup je ne pourrais pas
vous faire une petite chanson pour
meubler
à françoise et très consciencieuse ces
bons françoise
ah ah ah
bah parfait vous pouvez vous lever s'il
vous plaît et c'est maintenant que les
applaudissements fusent vous pouvez
rejoindre place
[Applaudissements]
et avant de rejoindre votre place vous
allez nous désigner une personne de
votre choix françoise
thierry je connais thiery
[Applaudissements]
fabien bon on se connaît parce que on
est conférencier tous les os n'est ce
pas
on n'est pas compris ça on est d'accord
alors en plus s'est dit d'accord je
comprend mieux alors il faut s'asseoir
maintenant
alors tiré voilà ce qui va se passer
en fait c'est une interrogation orale on
va voir si thierry a bien suivi
prévoir
je pose étant déjà à faut pas
s'inquiéter c'est un tour qui fonctionne
une fois sur deux et hier soir il a
fonctionné
est-ce que je peux avoir votre main
droite vous vous rappelez du premier
comportement clé c'est lequel
ça fait plaisir c'était d'être dans
l'action
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à bien
le deuxième le deuxième comportement clé
c'était
c'est quoi ces
c'était quoi d'être
d'avoir du leadership on va dire que
j'ai du leader chic vous êtes d'accord
thierry et a plus joué de toute façon
plus le choix attention attention ou
pressé pas donc vous allez confiance en
moi
[Musique]
et le troisième comportement clé c'était
il sait plus et puis là c'est
un petit mouchoir pour essuyer là ça
commence chez
les champions de la dernière c'est un
type qui pensaient différemment sortir
de la boîte donc on va faire les choses
différemment on va prendre les deux
mains comme ceux ci et c'est vous qui
allez décider vous préférez votre faim
la main droite ou la main gauche je dis
on va casser la gauche
[Applaudissements]
merci
alors vous aussi vous pouvez écarter le
risque comme thierry si vous appliquez
tous les principes qu'on a vus ensemble
nous invite à faire merci à vous
[Applaudissements]